the government's currently throwing a
lot at reopening the economy but today's
been proof it was never going to be easy
have a look at this these are just a few
of the big brands they've already said
they're gonna have to make redundancies
big names in here from aviation
manufacturing retail and hospitality
some you might remember British Airways
they said they're going to have to cut
about 12,000 jobs the owners of
Uppercross about 5,000 it all amounts to
tens of thousands of jobs loss from
across the economy and now there's more
bad news from the high street boots a
huge employer has announced its cutting
about four thousand jobs that's around 7
percent of the workforce and it's
closing 48 branches of boots opticians
it blames football that's the number of
people in shops boots actually stayed
open throughout the pandemic but look
footfall was down 85 percent in April
then there's John Lewis the high street
favorite it's putting 1,300 jobs at risk
and cutting eight of its shops that
includes the department stores in
Birmingham Grand Central and also the
one in Watford as well but it's John
Lewis's reasoning that will really
rattle the high street retailers before
this pandemic around 40 percent of its
sales were online it's now forecasting
that could be 60 to 70 percent
it says the pandemic has simply
accelerated existing trends from the
high street to online shopping look at
this data from springboard the retail
consultants you can see the total
collapse in footfall genlock down now
that's hardly a surprise but it's this
bit here when the shops were reopened in
about mid June those numbers simply
didn't recover now it's the timing as
well of these redundancies that's
particularly bad for the chance that
remember he's only just unveiled his big
plan for creating and protecting jobs
but his focus was largely hospitality
with nothing specific for sectors like
retail lovely to have more now I think
you know it as long as he stays open to
the potential for the need to provide
further support in in the future you
know that is that's a good-ass retail
certainly isn't the Oh
any sector that's struggling to recover
others also feel overlooked yes the
economy's reopening but it's been
changed by the pandemic many jobs will
no longer exist